prenez deux équipes de 11 joueurs armés
d'une crosse un terrain de plus de 90
mètres de long et une balle et vous avez
un match de hockey sur gazon
mélangeant geste de tennis de football
et de golf une fois que l'on a dit ça la
seconde phase de coupe du monde se
dérouler cette semaine à saint germain
en laye face aux faibles portugais le
jeu tricolore manque d'impact physique
et surtout de précision dans les tirs
l'attak réalise 1 0 sur 5 sur penalty
corner et doit attendre le quart d'heure
de jeu pour ouvrir le score
le camp des loges respire un peu plus
quatre minutes plus tard grâce à
matthieu durchon au retour des
vestiaires bis repetita les bleus
évoluant à la maison semble envahi par
la pression ratant souvent des passes
faciles les penaltys corners
s'enchaînent et l'artisan lucas sevestre
trouve enfin le chemin des filets à deux
reprises
43e et 57e 4 0 les bleus de france
s'impose finalement 6 0 le score est
flatteur mais la manière n'y est pas je
crois qu'on essaie de jouer sérieusement
mais je je je sais pas il n'ya pas les
liens qu'il fallait y avait pas l'envi
qu'il fallait donc oui peut-être que
finalement il a pris un peu un peu au
dessus et ça pardonne pas et puis bah
franchement on est tombé sur une équipe
portugaise qui s'est bien battue
nous on reste quand même déçu de la
prestation générale 6 face aux modestes
portugais l'essentiel est préservé les
bleus n'ont pas réalisé l'exploit face
aux belges
deux jours plus tard en s'inclinant de
justesse 3 2 les joueurs de stéphane
soyez devront attendre le 2 juin et le
verdict de l'autre poule 2 world league
en russie pour espérer faire partie des
trois meilleurs deuxièmes et continuer
leur chemin vers les jeux olympiques de
rio